it's a bird it's a plane nope that's
just the regalia type F the famous
flying car if you're wondering how you
can get behind the wheel of this whip I
have some good news and some bad news
the good news is that if you've been
playing through the story you're on the
right track the bad news is that you'll
have to finish the game before you can
get this in order to unlock the regalia
type F you need to take down the three
Niflheim bases you will deal with to
these bases just by following the story
the third one however you probably won't
get around to until you finish the game
this one is located just north of
hammerhead around here after you've
dealt with the three bases and completed
the story head over to Cindy and she'll
upgrade the car for you oh now I get it
this must be what Papa meant when he
said he was gonna teach them boys a
lesson once she's done it's time to hit
the skies if you're playing on ps4 just
hit the circle button and you're off for
more on Final Fantasy 15 you're already
in the right place
[Music]